using his book on the wright brothers
then queen elizabeth speaks at the state
opening of the british parliament
[Music]
this week on q a our guest is two-time
pulitzer prize winner david mccullough
out with his new book the wright
brothers
he talks about the personal stories of
wilbur and orville wright the roles
their family played as the brothers
experienced failures and successes
and the time period in which they lived
as the race to achieve manned flight was
at its peak
[Music]
david mccullough i recently picked up
the
washington post on a sunday and saw a
review of your book written by a woman
named reeve lindbergh how about that and
she says mccullough's magical account of
their early adventures we're talking
about the wright brothers enhanced by
volumes of family correspondence written
records and his own deep understanding
of the country and the era
shows as never before how two ohio boys
from a remarkable family taught the
world to fly
reeve lindbergh did you expect that from
her it's one of it's as if i don't know
the pope had uh had blessed the book to
have her write that review meant more to
me than i can say it have you ever met
her no yes i have met her but i don't
really know her i did know her mother
and did a long interview
with her mother
um
years ago when i was doing the hosting
this
pbs series called smithsonian world and
she was wonderful
delightful to talk to and very winsome
as a person daughter of charles
lindbergh
no her mother's the one i interviewed
but the daughter is the one that wrote
this review and what i really liked
about what you just read is she said a
remarkable family
they really were a remarkable family and
the book
i like to think is as much about the
family it's a family story it's a family
saga what was going on in the world in
the early 1900s when the wright brothers
started their
their their inventing well relatively
speaking it was a fairly
placid time there were no major wars and
we were not at war
and we were prospering it was the
economy was good very good
and
we
had a sense of
of
progress
and prosperity and
and confidence i think and it was a very
exciting time for
innovations of all kinds inventions
the light bulb the
the elevator the telephone the mouse
trap
the cash register on and on and they
they the wright brothers very much were
involved in all of that felt that it was
a renaissance time if you look upon
innovation and invention as an art form
um
and
dayton had the most number of patents
issued to citizens of the city
on a per capita basis of any city in the
country
so it was a dayton was hot
it was a silicon valley in a way of the
time so they were in the midst of
something really exciting going on and i
think people felt the americans could do
anything
we were about to build the panama canal
undertaking a project that the french
had failed at the most momentous
undertaking our country had ever
taken upon itself
and that was that was good the future
looked good nobody realized that the
horrors of world war one were over the
horizon
the wright brothers in order to do your
research for this book where did you
have to go
well as you know brian i always feel i
have to go where things happen so i had
to go to kitty hawk i had to go to
dayton i had to go to the ford museum at
dearborn michigan where the right house
and the right bicycle shop are now
located
i had to go to paris because the very
important part of the story took place
there so i said to myself well you've
got to go to paris
and it had to go to le mans where
wilbur wright
demonstrated what their plane could do
for the world as the world was
astonished to see
and then down to po france which is very
near the spanish border
just with the pyramids pyramids and the
pyrenees in the distance
and um
and i i i benefited from each and every
one of those places in my sense of what
they did and where they were and so
forth
but i would say the most important place
of all
were was the house
inside that house which is exactly as it
was
because when they turned it over to the
ford museum orville supervised it all he
was all done under his
his uh
agreement and his
sense of what it should look like so you
walk in the door and there's all exactly
as it was
and the idea that
out of this little house
had no running water
no indoor plumbing no electricity
no telephone came this phenomenal
idea
these two phenomenal
uh people who changed the world
um
but what you do see in the house
in the
in spite of the absence of all those
other things where lots of books
and that's the big part of their story
their father
insisted they read
read everything read fiction read
history natural history
philosophy
and he insisted that they learn
to use the english language properly
how much education did the wright
brothers have
formal education was ended with high
school they didn't even graduate from
high school
but that was largely because their
father always said encourage them if
they had some interesting project they
were working on he'd say stay home and
do that you don't have to go to school
because he knew how bright they were
wilbur i think without any question was
a genius
uh orville was very bright very
inventive clever mechanically
but he didn't have the
reach of mind that wilbur had and wilbur
was a natural leader and he was the
older brother the big brother he was the
boss
and
their sister was also very bright
and one of the pleasures of this book
has been able to bring her out of the
shadows because she belongs front and
center and downstage
she was
i don't i'm not sure that
it would have turned out the way it did
it had it not been for her
and
i love to give credit where credit's
long overdue and she deserves a lot of
credit when i started out i didn't know
anything about them
much more than all of us
learned in 10 minutes in high school
they were from ohio they had a bicycle
shop and they invented the airplane but
it's much much more than that
you're a research assistant on many of
these books a guy named mike hill yes
was here a couple years ago
to talk about his book yes and when he
was here i asked him and we'll show you
this clip about what your book was going
to be about now and you gave him
permission to talk about let's watch
this and see if you lived up to your
promise
he working on another book
he is uh and i know you worked him over
pretty good last time he was here and he
didn't crack
but i talked to him before i came on
here and he said it was it was okay to
tell you
the way it's looking now is that the
narrative arc of the of the book would
would uh start
in the early age of infancy with uh
with the wright brothers doing some of
their early
tests outside paris in 1908 1909
and then as as as aviation exploded not
only as a as a technological instrument
but also as a cultural cultural icon
take that obviously then through world
war one and the american aviators who
who
who fought overseas uh and and how
aviation then can convert it into this
instrument of war and then take it
forward out of the war into the 20s and
then the ark would would begin to taper
off with lindbergh landing in paris and
in may of 1927.
did you do that no
no i didn't i because i decided it was
to keep it right to the wright brothers
because the this huge collection of
letters
that are in the library of congress
they're the professional letters which
number in well over a thousand
and diaries
and log books and technical books in
their own handwriting but in addition to
that
there are well over a thousand private
family correspondence letters written
strictly for each other in the family
and since they wrote superbly their use
of the english language
is humbling
um again the father insisted they know
how to write a good letter give a good
talk and so forth
and these letters are long
and never boring
and you hear all about what's on their
minds what they think was funny what
they're
having trouble with
catherine could get pretty feisty sister
sister
rathy she said i can be wrathy
but she was also very funny they were
all three were very funny
and
once we got into those letters i really
this is this is the book
so my book really ends in 1910
once they
once they'd achieved what they set out
to do
and that's
wonderfully graphically illustrated
by the fact that until then
they had refused ever to ride together
in a plane because
there was always the chance they could
get killed every time they went up
they knew this their courage was
phenomenal
and
they wouldn't ride together because if
one of them got killed they wanted the
other one to be around to carry on with
a mission to complete their objective
but in 1910 they decided that they would
put on an exhibition for the people of
dayton
at the
cow pasture whether they did a lot of
their experimental work
and so they invited the town to come out
and watch and the two of them got in a
plane together and flew together
which was symbolically saying we've done
what we set out to do and
not everybody but a lot of people there
understood exactly the symbolism of that
moment
here's some video from
the first flight
uh 1903
yes at kitty hawk about 55 seconds let's
watch this and you can fill in the
blanks
in 1903 two imaginative bicycle
mechanics felt they had a heavier than
air machine which could carry a man
aloft in sustained controlled flight
wilbur and orville wright after four
years of experimentation gave the glider
a water-cooled 12 horsepower engine
which they designed themselves the
engine powered two chain driven pusher
type propellers
december 17 1903 was a cold windy day at
kitty hawk north carolina by the toss of
a coin orville won the chance to become
the first man in history to fly under
power the first flight covering a
distance of 120 feet lasted only 12
seconds
four flights were made that day and the
last flight covered 852 feet in 59
seconds
[Music]
did you say in your book that that plane
was never used again
yes but the end of that film that was
not the plane that flew at kitty hawk
that's the one that was developed
playing the fluid kitty hawk was not a
practical plane all it really did was
take off and land it they didn't yet
know how to bank and turn fly in a
figure eight or a circle
it wasn't until 1905
that they had perfected that kind of a
plane which is one that was shown there
in the latter part of that film and
that's flying at huffman prairie as it
was called
in dayton
the plane was never used again that's
correct where is it now
it's it was reconstructed and it's now
in the smithsonian institution where
it's been for a long time
what what kind of competition was there
back then in the early 1900s to be the
first people flying an airplane
there was a lot of
experimentation going on but no real
competition they were ahead of everybody
and most all of that was in france there
was none here
now there's a claim that a man named
whitehead up in connecticut
flew first there's nothing to it there's
no no evidence no proof nothing
um
and if he did fly which he didn't
he never flew again and when he went to
flies a plane that he had built it
wouldn't fly
even his own family said he never flew
um
but there was that talk but in france it
was taken rather seriously
but when finally the date the time came
when wilbur went to france to
demonstrate before the french what he
and
orville had achieved
all the french aviators said we are but
children compared to them they're way
ahead of us
and that first demonstration took place
on the eighth day of the eighth month
of the year 1908 august 8
1908 at le mans france
and
the astonishment the excitement was
beyond anything anyone remembered
and soon tens of thousands of people
were coming to watch wilbur wright fly
and the whole world knew that the
airplane was a real
a real event that the man could fly and
then the wright brothers instantly
became
two of the most famous people on earth
here's a this is from the u.s air force
and this is for at le mans france yes
wilbur wright went to europe in 1980
find a market for the flying machine
which up to then they were unable to
sell
his flights on the continent attracted
the president of france as well as the
kings of england spain and italy
to wilbur it was endless work in
addition to acting as pilot he was
ground crew mechanic and salesman
a team of forces pulled the plane to a
wooden monorail this was to serve as a
runway on the grassy field
lifted by a few men
the flying machine was swung into
position facing the wind
to provide thrust for the takeoff the
rights had developed a weight-falling
catapult
after the props were spun the engine
picked over
wilbur and his passenger or french
journalist took seats on the lower wing
and braced themselves for an exciting
ride
he convinced europe winning applause but
no sale
convinced but no sale who was trying to
sell
whom
well theoretically uh the the french
army was going to buy
the planes and one thing developed or
another and they didn't
i've never seen that film before that is
terrific
and there's several things that i
noticed right away that read that he
walked very fast and he did he always
knew sort of where he was going and he
was uh
he meant business wilbur
orwell had a crash in
the united states here at the fort
across
across the way for meyer and
he came over eventually to france but he
was walking on a cane and we couldn't
fly
so all the demonstrations in france
which were
numerous
and drew huge crowds were all conducted
by wilbur
and um
and the french appreciated it whereas
our government didn't our government
took no interest in it until after he'd
become such a big
sensation in europe
and
it's it's in the newspapers newspapers
in
dayton ohio wouldn't even send reporters
out to watch what these fellows were
doing eight miles out of town
and one of the editors later on was
asked how in the world could you just
have sat in here and ignored all that
and the man said i don't know i guess we
were just plain stupid and i think
that's
what it was but also this
it was a fixed notion
in people's minds that man can't fly
and no and
they refuse to believe it even when it
was happening literally right under
their noses go back to what you said
about fort myers and the crash of one of
the planes and somebody was killed there
what's that story how and how bad was it
it was very bad um it was a mechanical
failure
of the plane it wasn't the fault of the
pilot or anything
and they dove straight down into the
ground from about 75 feet
and a young army lieutenant who was
flying with him a man named selfridge
was killed first
aviation fatality ever
and wilbur was very badly hurt leg
broken in two places ribs badly
sprained or
broken but he was also badly damaged
psychologically
very shaken up and very
unsure of himself
catherine
sister back in ohio was school teacher
high school latin teacher
got worried that this has happened she
called the school principal said she was
taking an indefinite leave of absence
in about two hours had packed and was on
the next train that day to washington
came here
stayed out at fort myers
uh in the hospital with him for at least
a month in a month and a week or more
and
saw to it that his care was the best
possible
but also
trying to give him encouragement
and spirit back to come back to himself
and i think in some ways she saved his
life he not only recovered excuse me
eventually
so that he was able to walk again there
was even some concern about that
but to fly again he came back both
catherine and wilbur thought he
shouldn't try to fly again at fort myers
that would be too tough psychologically
for him to have to cope with he said no
it's got to be there so he not only got
back on the horse he got back on the
same horse in the same place and he then
proceeded to break a lot of records
flying superbly for everybody to see
as you know out here where the cia is
located is a place called langley
virginia
and down in the south part of the state
of virginia is langley air force base
the reason i bring it up is the langley
name was big back there you write it
about him in your book and you make the
point more than once
that
wilbur and orwell wright did this whole
thing on private money
and that langley had federal money and
it didn't work
well
wilbur once said there are two ways to
train
a wild horse
one of them is to sit on a fence
and observe the horse take notes and
then go to a comfortable chair in your
comfortable house and write up a
paper on how you
train a wild horse the other way is to
get on the horse and ride
and he said that's the way we go about
our
project
langley sat on the fence and watched the
horse in other words
samuel langley was the secretary or head
of the smithsonian institution he was a
brilliant american scientist and a man
of great importance
uh ran up
the after the
observatory
uh in western pennsylvania before he
became secretary of the smithsonian
and he was avidly interested in aviation
and he built this giant
contraption that looked like a giant
bug of some kind
and
it took off and just
went up and dove into the
potomac river more than once
yes yes there was a pilot not langley he
wasn't going to go up somebody went up
and uh they're all kinds of people who
defend langley and saying it was a pro
fault of his launching
apparatus and so forth nonetheless it
did fail
and they had put 70 000 into it and that
was a lot of money in those days a hell
of a lot of money
and most of it was public money
government money but smithsonian money
and for nothing
the wright brothers
built their plane
brought it all the way to kitty hawk
traveled back and forth and so forth
everything
all expenses covering all expenses
themselves and they did it for less than
a thousand dollars
on their own
they had no financial help from anybody
no foundation no university no
government
pension or whatever
and uh
and
it was all savings
from the rather
modest
income that they got from their bicycle
business
how many bikes did they sell
well in a good year 50 or so
um and they made them themselves and
then the little shop was
still there in dearborn michigan
why did that i mean did they move that
physically the shop from the day one
thing and the house from dayton ohio to
dearborn well the ford museum of
dearborn is about saving historic
buildings that's what it is
and
in some ways it's too bad that it was
taken away from
from hawthorne street in
in dayton but on the other hand it might
not have survived and the bicycle shot
might not have survived and as it was
it's still there exactly as it was
you're talking about fort myers and i
want to bring this up again i want to
show some video of that crash or that
attempt there where lieutenant selfridge
was killed and orville was wounded uh
badly
and then put into perspective
again why langley was able to get the
money to try to build a plane and then
the wright brothers couldn't get the
government interested let's watch this
they signed the contract on february 10
1908 and 200 days later orville
delivered the right flyer to fort myer
virginia where initial flight testing
began
there were several setbacks including a
crash which required the construction of
a new airplane
the crash took the life of lieutenant
thomas e selfridge who was flying as
orville wright's passenger he became the
army's first aviation fatality
orville sustained severe injuries in
this matchup
why were they here at fort myers which
is right over the bridge here
demonstrating for the government
what what they could do how did they get
to do that
they were invited finally by the
government to do it because
once the excitement of what had happened
in france
had sunk in here
and um
they're really
they really were demonstrating for the
for the war department for the for the
military as they were in france
and
there was little interest as
at the as of that point
in in the a future of passenger
transportation
it was thought that and it was thought
that for the prey war
for an army or or military campaign it
would be used primarily for
reconnaissance
and for sending messages rapidly and so
forth
the idea that it would be a weapon
it hadn't entered in many heads yet
how do you teach yourself this story
what's your technique
where did you write this one by the way
because i read
i mean did you give up your um
uh your
tissberry road no
no part of it was written there and
we rosey and i decided we were grown up
enough now we could also have an
apartment
in boston so part of it was written
there and
and part was written
uh on the vineyard in the little
what some people call a shed
but it to me it's world headquarters out
behind the house where i've written so
many of my books but how do you teach
yourself this story
how do you go about it
well in our line of work we have what
are called primary and secondary sources
the secondary sources are books or
articles that have been written in say
the last 50 years or so and you start
with those
and then but as soon as you possibly can
you get into the primary sources which
are the letters and diaries
and newspaper articles and testimony
taken at the time and so forth
with the real thing
written at the time and you just soak
yourself in it you re read all you can
and then you start writing
and
as you write
you realize how many questions
keep arising because you don't have the
answers and then you go and look for the
answers
and
and sometimes
you really hit it you hit something that
nobody's found before and that's
exciting
with this book it was the
mystery of who it was
that hit wilbur in the teeth with the
hockey stick knocked out all his upper
teeth when he was 18.
and sent him into a
spell of depression and self-imposed
seclusion in his house for three years
was not not able to go to college which
he had planned to do
he wanted to go to yale instead he
stayed at home
very seldom ever went out at all
reading
and providing himself
with a liberal arts education of a kind
most people would dream of having all on
his own
with the help of his father and the
local public library
but it was it swerved his
the path of his life in a way that no
one had ever had any way of anticipating
so the question was who hid him
and was it
an accident or was it intentional
and i found out
reading the bishop his father's diary
in an entry written long after wilbur
had died more than a year after wilbur
died
and it turned out it was a boy who was
known as the neighborhood bully
and he
his name was oliver
howe
and he
he then
later on became one of the most
notorious murderers in the history of
ohio
killed his mother his father
his brother and estimated 12 others
besides
but then you read the story of this boy
his family was very poor
and he had no money to spend on
dentistry
and he had rotting teeth
and intense pain
and he worked as a clerk
in a drug store and the druggist feeling
very sorry for him
gave him painkillers which in those days
were cocaine pills
and he became addicted to to cocaine as
one does and alcohol had to be
institutionalized in an insane asylum
when he got out he then went on his
his murder binge
was executed in
1906.
so
wilbur was gone by the time
the bishop was willing to set the sec
the record straight in his diary and
oliver howe was also gone
too
but i think the it's important
very important
because there's a tendency to see this
charming little street where the rights
grew up
and the father who was such an admirable
man and
sister and how much education counted
and booked it's kind of a norman
rockwell setting
but yet just around the corner was this
very
tragic
story
of a boy
who went
bad if anyone ever could imagine someone
going bad how did you find that it was
in the bishop's diary did you find it by
reading the whole diary or no the diary
has been published the diary is amazing
but no one apparently read that far or
something i don't know why
and
then of course we did the research
my friend mike hill that you've just
mentioned
um
who's
very important part of my working
process
uh did the digging on on the murderer
and came up with all kinds of material
as one would find of this notorious
murderer but whether he hit wilbur
intentionally or accidentally we still
don't know
by the way i have another clip i want to
show you of mike hills was one of my
favorites from the interview i did with
him uh you'll see why okay let's run
this
one of the things that david taught me
very early on
was to engage the archivists in the
library librarians in the process tell
them what you're doing
because i've heard a lot of stories from
archivists and librarians that authors
and historians will come in and they're
very
focused on what they want to do but the
things we've found just by talking to
archivists is really pretty remarkable
so how do you know
when david mccullough is mad
angry
irritated
you don't
i don't get mad i get i get frustrated
sometimes
and i get um
impatient
and i think
patience
your capacity for patience diminishes
with age because
you know times
times running out you don't want to
waste any time
and
but i'm so glad that he made that point
about the archivists and the and the uh
librarians and and the immense help they
are
uh
every single person that i give credit
to in the acknowledgements in my books
is somebody who has done something of
very great value for my work i think
that one of the more obvious
lessons of history is almost nothing of
any consequence is accomplished in ice
by the individual by a lone person it's
a joint effort and certainly uh this
kind of
scholarship or whatever one wishes to
call it is always a joint effort
and i've had time and again i've had a
librarian or an archivist say to me you
remember when you were in here a year
ago and you were looking well i found it
and um sometimes it can be very exciting
material
the wright brothers when you as you
started to learn what they were like uh
what did you find
what would they be like if you were
sitting they were sitting here in your
talk they could talk with you about
almost anything
they weren't just interested in aviation
uh wilbur loved architecture and wrote
these marvelous letters back from paris
describing the great
uh french architecture particularly
gothic architecture that he
was so overwhelmed by
and
i to me and he doesn't say this but i
can't help feeling gothic architecture
is reaching for the skies reaching
upward that's just what he wanted to do
it was his
form of a cathedral
and
he was very interested in painting at
every chance he would go to the louvre
and spend hours looking at paintings and
really looking at them and thinking
which painting did he like and which did
he not like and why and wrote again
these delightful letters home to his
sister his or his father about it
uh
they loved music
they loved books
nathaniel hawthorne was oliver it was
orville's favorite
writer
um
catherine loved sir walter scott in fact
with one of her birthdays the brothers
gave her a bust of sir walter scott
now here these people living in this
little house in ohio with no running
water no indoor plumbing
no electricity and they're giving a bust
of a great english
literary giant to their sister for a
birthday present
there's a lot of hope in that
but i think what what i would like to
get to know even more about was the
sense of purpose that they had
and it sounds like a
bad pun but high purpose not not
something ordinary big idea we're going
to achieve this big idea
nothing was going to stop them back in
december of 1903 when they flew down
there and uh and there's wilbur that
flew down kitty
how old were they orville i mean or
wherever was the first flyer yes how old
were they
well orville was in his late 30s and
wilbur's early 40s
but when they started
this whole business how old were they
when they had their bike shop they
figured out they started really got
going in 1899.
uh they were
wilbur would have been in his 30s
orville might have been already in his
early 30s i'd have to do the math and
where what's the difference between the
ages of wilber four and a half years and
then catherine yes
catherine and orville were very close in
age and much closer for many years in
childhood
uh
than wilbur and orville were wilbur and
orville could fight like dogs they would
argue something terrible but then by the
end of the argument they'd switched
sides and each was taking the same
position as the other one at the
beginning it's a riot
but they were arguing with their way of
working problems out they weren't
as charlie taylor who worked with him
said they weren't mad at each other they
were just trying to get to the answer
and they had different ideas of how to
get to it and that's one of the ways
they would get to it
there's another name i know when i was
growing up in indiana there was a
chanute air force base over in illinois
and you write about a guy named chaneu
who was octave chinook well he was a
born in france uh he was french but came
to america and he was
one of the preeminent
civil engineers of the day great bridge
builder railroad builder who took an
active interest
in flight
and particularly gliding
it all begins with gliding but like
langley chinook would never
try himself to go in a glider he had
somebody else do that the one who did do
a lot of gliding and was really the
pioneer of gliding
was
lillianthal otto lillianthal a german
and he was killed
in
his glider experiments
we've got some video of that let's watch
that and explain who otto he was a
german yes
and paul let's watch
when you look at this picture you can
see
one of the great problems that
lillianthal faced clearly lillianthal is
able to build wings that will lift the
weight of his glider and his own body
into the air one of the really
important contributions that he makes in
fact are to be found in photographs like
this when people around the world saw
pictures of this guy in the air like
this you know you could not you could no
longer doubt that the age of flight was
about to dawn but when you look at this
picture you can see his great problem
too
you can see what's happened he's been
flying along coming toward us and a gust
of wind perhaps has has struck his right
wing tip and lifted it and the only way
he has to control his glider to bring
that wingtip down is to swing his own
weight to that side of the airplane
who was that was that tom crouch i
actually don't know yeah well
it's all quite right yeah he's hanging
from the glider
and he can't really control it uh
sufficiently and they saw that that was
it was the problem just as he said it
was tom craft
and uh tom crouch is the leading
authority on the history of aviation
he's
curator
senior curator of aviation
at the uh
smithsonian's air and space museum it's
a wonderful man it was very helpful to
me
but
what the wright brothers developed
was they called
wing warping and they arrived at that
solution
by studying soaring birds
in other words birds that can get up in
the air and then they just ride the wind
they don't flap their wings and they
would watch these birds by the hour
in dayton but even more so when they got
down to kitty hawk where the soaring
birds were
in multitudes particularly the gannet
which is a giant soaring seabird with a
wingspan of five or six feet
and if i could have
your book
i'd like to read you
a line
of the of an eyewitness to them
trying to study the soaring birds
his name was
john daniel and he was a local guy
um
in kitty hawk
who
like many of the people there when they
first saw these brothers thought they
were crazy
we couldn't help thinking they were just
a pair of poor nuts
they'd stand on the beach for hours at a
time
just looking at the gulls flying soaring
dipping
cannons
they would watch those gannets and
imitate the movements of their wings
with their arms and hands they could
imitate every moment movement of the
wings of those cannons and we thought
they were playing crazy
but we just had to admire the way they
could move their arms this way and that
and bend their elbows and wrist bones up
and down and which way just like the
gannets
now years later orville said
learning the secret of flight from a
bird was a good deal like learning the
secret of magic from a magician
isn't that great
there's here is a problem
some of the greatest minds in all
history had tried to solve
and they solved it by watching the
soaring birds how do they ride the wind
and
and
um
by doing so they invented this wing
warping which would twist the wing and
there that way they could bank and turn
but it's all about what in aviation
terms is called equilibrium but it's
balance
and so is riding a bicycle and
just as you have to get on a bicycle and
ride it in order to learn how to ride a
bicycle you have to get on the wind and
ride it in order to ride the wind and
they knew that
and that's where they that's where they
made their progress in a way that nobody
else had
going back to the video it showed otto
lillianthal died in 1894
yes how much did were they paying
attention then
well it was his death in his obituary
that started wilbur reading about the
subject
we have some video from
the bike shop or the ex actually the
wright brothers museum in dayton yes uh
let's watch that so sure we had our
cameras out there
the centerpiece of the park is the
wright brothers aviation center
the wright brothers aviation center is a
four building complex which consists of
a replica of their famous bicycle shop
two galleries filled with original
wright brothers artifacts and the
centerpiece of the wright brothers
aviation center is wright hall which is
a building constructed in 1950
specifically built to house the 1905
wright flyer 3. this was the third and
final experimental airplane that the
wright brothers built and today survives
as the second oldest of their airplanes
today
this airplane which orville wright
considered the world's first practical
airplane
was constructed and flown in less than
six years time between the time that
they built their kite
and the success of this particular
airplane what's interesting to think
about is that the right flyer and kitty
hawk flew four times just four times on
one very historic day there were four
very important flights and they very
much were the proof of concept of
powered heavier than air flight but the
airplane behind me the 1905 wright flyer
3 was capable of repeated takeoffs and
landings repeated flights of not just
for a few seconds at a time but upwards
of 40 minutes by october of 1905.
that's exactly right
that
that plane that's on exhibit there in
dayton
is in many ways the beginning of
aviation much more than the plane that
flew at kitty hawk and that's the plane
that they took to france to demonstrate
to the world we can fly
and um
it would
it wasn't sufficient to them
to just fly
in she was we did it
they had to make it practical
and when they came back from that first
triumph of 1903 and december 17th
their mind wasn't on oh look aren't we
nifty didn't we do this great thing it
was here's what we got to do next they
were always looking to the future what
what could how could they make it better
how could they achieve something that
was an improvement
and they loved their work
i think that's key to understanding them
they had purpose and they loved their
work and oh my could they work that same
john daniels that described them looking
like crackpots said they were the
workingest boys i ever saw in my life
well as you know wilbur died at age 45
in 1912 yes of what typhoid fever
it's like a greek tragedy the father had
been warning them since they were little
boys watch out for unpure water always
have pure water
and we forget that wasn't very long ago
that you couldn't assume that the water
you were getting in any american city
was pure
my granddaughter just came back from a
trip
to vietnam and thailand
and i'd said to her
there's an old saying the country when
you travel abroad the country you learn
the most about is your own
what do you come back home
thankful for what do you see as a
blessing that we
have here that you weren't sufficiently
uh appreciative of that you didn't
sufficiently appreciate she said pure
water
and
i think that the advances that we've
made in health and medicine which we all
take for granted
are what the future historians are going
to see is the most important thing
that's happened in our lifetime
orville
lived to 1948 yes
77 years old
what did he do after wilbur had died and
did they make any money
yes they did make money they they became
wealthy they didn't become super wealthy
uh wilbur never lived to see the money
come rolling in
in a big way orville and catherine did
uh orville and wilbur norvell did not
like business and they did not like
legal battles
and they were very unhappy with anything
of that kind
um
wilbur got out pretty quickly orville
rather got out of it pretty quickly and
retired to sort of tinkering with
scientific ideas that he had
and
he had always been rather reclusive and
shy and he became increasingly so with
age
at one point and you know we ran the
mike hill clip earlier about what you'd
plan to do with the book going all the
way to lindbergh what point did you
decide this was only going to be about
the wright brothers
i think when i began to sense how
exceptional and how many lessons are to
be learned from their story just as
human beings
i would have been happy to have written
this book even if they had failed to
attain their objective
so admirable
is so much about
how they went through life they were
modest
they were never affected or changed by
success or fame
they were they were kind
they were they never criticized in any
way their rivals
or anyone who criticized them
they
they weren't in it for the money
absolutely were not in it for the money
and
they were loyal loyal to their town
loyal to their family
i see many similarities
to harry truman
in the wright brothers
they came from the middle west they grew
up at pretty much the same time
they never went to college but they
didn't let that stand in their way but
they also never stopped reading
most people have no idea that harry
truman read latin for pleasure
the wright brothers were very much like
that
and
they would not give up
i think that's crucial
they would not give up
they could get knocked down flat they
could be ridiculed they could be
criticized
they could crash literally crash
they could
suddenly find that all the
statistical data they were basing all
their
designs on which had been long
established as the
uh the god word about aviation
it was all wrong and they had to start
all over again they didn't let that stop
them nothing but they wouldn't give up
you say that and i think that's a hugely
admirable point and a very important
point for all of us to know how do you
handle failure
do you when you get knocked down do you
lie there and cry
do you resort to
self-pity do you blame other people or
do you get back up and go at what you
have to do having learned something
from why you failed why you got knocked
down you talk about the the orville and
wilbur wright never married but their
sister catherine
got married
when she was like 52 or so yes uh
what impact did that have on her
relationship with uh orville well it's a
very sad story
orville through much of his life had
what in the family were called his
peculiar spells
and he would get very touchy and moody
and
and brewed uh but they wouldn't last
terribly long
this was the worst of his peculiar
spells by far
and it was he inflicted terribly
terrible pain on his
sister whom he adored
when she denounced that she wanted to
get married to a man
she'd known for they both had known for
a long time
and she and the fellow
served together on the board of
directors of overland college where
she'd gone to college
that she wanted to get married that was
going to get married
he refused to talk to her
again
he felt that he'd been betrayed
and when she was she moved to kansas
city where he was an editor on the
kansas city star
and when he heard that she was dying he
he wasn't very
quick to go to her bedside but he
eventually did
but it's a sad
and regrettable
into a otherwise wonderful
relationship between brother and sister
we've got some more video from wright
state this one's from wright state
university and it has photos of the fort
myers crash and all
and let's run that a little bit and get
your reaction to
this one of the really
interesting things we have in the
collection is this photograph album this
was put together by ch cloudy who was a
reporter for the new york herald
and he took lots of photographs of
orville flying at fort myer virginia in
1908 and 1909 when orville was trying to
sell the airplane to the u.s army signal
corps
and it includes newspaper clippings and
original photographs documenting all the
flights in 08 and 09 down at fort myer
virginia
it includes
lots of photographs of the crash that
orville was in that killed lieutenant
selfridge the first aircraft accident
victim
when orville had that crash his sister
catherine left her teaching job in
dayton and went to fort myer virginia to
nurse him back to health and be by his
side
you know
one of the things that people said about
your book i've read a tiny bit of
criticism about the fact that this story
has been done so many times i'm sure
you've read that
did you worry about that in this process
not a bit
because
if anybody reads the book and thinks
that this story has been done many times
they didn't really
read much of the book because
there's an awful lot in this book that
has not been done many times including
about catherine
including about
who was wielding the hockey stick
including the interest that these
brothers had in art and music
and architecture
and much of
what happened in france very little bit
been written about it
we did research in the french newspapers
french
archives
and came up with a lot of new material
but i think what i would like to say is
that that
collection of photographs
at wright state university
was a huge help to me
in my writing of the book because you
can learn so much from photographs by
studying photographs
and the people at wright state were
immensely helpful wonderful people to
work with how did you get the publisher
of your book to let you put in 81
photographs and four different sections
because they love the photographs too
and they know that these photographs are
an immensely
important part of the story because the
wright brothers
loved photography
and they were in many ways experimenting
with photography too and they put took
pictures of everything they did
now
the easy
answer to why would they do that
was that they were inspired by
lillianthal who took pictures of
everything he did but also they were
keeping records of their accomplishments
and their
their
machinery that they were building
to protect themselves from people who
might try to
use the
what they would
patent as their own
the records of every step of everything
they ever did in life are thorough in
words photograph photographs diaries
everything in a way that almost i've
never seen before
unbelievable has this country given them
the kind of
credit for this that they deserve with
all these places you went can you help
me
yes yes absolutely once once it happened
while they were mocked and ignored for
so long before they succeeded after they
succeeded oh of course this is terrific
these are our wonderful dayton boys
welcome home the whole town shut down
for two days to celebrate
it was wonderful thought of you uh
some time ago when we were celebrating
the seventh 70th anniversary of d-day we
had the great flyover here and i'm going
to show you some video of that flyover
and see if you have any comment on sure
on what happened to aviation
in the early days of the war after the
allies had decided that the british
would conduct nighttime bombing raids on
german targets and the americans would
bomb during daylight hours
mission losses were horrific without
fighter escorts the us bombers in
particular suffered unsustainable losses
to german fighters and anti-aircraft
flack
by some estimates the fatality rate of
b-17 and b-24 crews was put at nearly 50
percent
that began to change with the
introduction of the p-51 mustang as a
long-range fighter when outfitted with
external fuel tanks made of a kind of
paper mache here come the mustangs
so um
what do you think what do you think
about what's happened to aviation
well i'm just going to say i built model
airplanes of the p50 a mustang
um
i was a boy when all this was happening
so i had a huge but to me it was just
exciting in the stream in in the extreme
well we we get all of us to get around
at um on these
we just take it for granted we're flying
at 30 35 000 40 000 feet at tremendous
speeds
last year alone
at one airport
o'hare in chicago
70 million people flew in and out of
that one airport
70 million
and we're sitting there and does anybody
and i was
flying on
on a flight to the west coast
and i was working on a chapter of my
book in the plane and i thought
how about this
and i could have known or will write
in other words it didn't happen all that
long ago as history goes
he died in 1948 i would have been 15
years old he might have been that nice
old fellow around the corner who i love
to talk to
you uh
you ended your book this way i want to
ask you when you decided to do this on
july 20th 18 i mean excuse me 1969 when
neil armstrong another american born and
raised in southwestern ohio stepped onto
the moon he carried with him in tribute
to the wright brothers a small swatch of
the muslim
uh muslin from a wing of their 1903
flyer yep at what point did you decide
that was the way you're going to end
your book soon as i read about it
there's just something so marvelous
about that the homage he's paying
his sense of
history his sense of indebtedness to the
courage of those predecessors those
pioneers these were pioneers
pioneers of the age we live in
and i don't it's to me it's fascinating
that neil armstrong
also came from that same corner of ohio
southwestern ohio
a matter of only 50 miles or so from
where the wright brothers grew up and
that john glenn also came from ohio now
whether that's coincidental or something
in the water out there in ohio i don't
know but i love that idea
and the fact that a pittsburgher is
paying tribute to ohio is significant
yes but never forget that the aluminum
that was the genius of their motor that
they built for the first airplane came
from pittsburgh
and the propeller of lindbergh's plane
is made of aluminum and that came from
pittsburgh i have to ask you as always
do uh do you plan to do another book
[Music]
yes i plan to keep writing it's my life
and i love it but what it will be i
don't know i'm waiting for mike hill to
find some good idea
our guest has been david mccullough this
is a book called the wright brothers and
we thank you very much
thank you bryce wonderful be back with
you
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
q a dot org q a programs are also
available as c-span podcasts
[Music]